[Music]
so
dante i am very curious and i want to
know
all of your your story of
hollywood who you [ __ ] no get out of
here so dante was a child star
and because of that he grew up in kind
of like in the hollywood
circle so he so he is always just either
knows him directly or has a few degrees
of separation
a lot of the stories that he tells is
very very interesting right yeah we all
want to live by character no we're just
going to play a game because we're
this is off the record yeah technically
technically the record
so we could just name random things or
random names and like
from the era from the era that i grew up
in which we're talking about
90s early 2000s and if maybe i got a
story that
if i cross paths with them i'll be like
this do you know them
okay john claude van damme
beat he's ass bro don't know john clyde
van damme directly i mean
the guys who produced uh with his first
movie produced a movie i did called
straight uh perfect weapon and so they
actually helped create who
jean-claude van damme was he was a
dancer he wasn't a martial he's a ballet
that's true like he knows how to like
yeah he was a ballet dancer he's not
really a martial artist he's a he's a
dancer which which makes sense because
when you do
martial arts on film it's all
choreography so it's all i i do well in
my sword fighting and hook and all these
things
because i'm a dancer so i see honestly
all the people that have trained
that used to be dancers they'd actually
become like really good fighters like
really quick transition really quickly
that's why bruce lee did the chat chat
yeah
that's why you're so good so yeah so i
don't know so that's a strike i don't
know
do you know but separated yeah because
they still produce your film right and
they produce this film kelly clarkson
what something that's that's way later
that's way later
hey you're not allowed to play anymore
robin williams let's talk about it
let's talk about it actually i do want
to hear a story from robin williams i
love it that's true
i feel like we're doing a bedtime story
tell me a story tell me a story
how was it like working with them no
robin's of course robin's great
he's amazing he's like the genie and
aladdin he's just
magical he's really dope though like we
did a lot
we talked a lot about poetry because
when we started the movie i i you were
into deaf
poetry well before deaf poetry i loved
deadpool society
and that was so big going into it so we
would talk about poetry we need to talk
about all these poets he loved and
poets i loved and um and i continued to
write poetry and he
he was kind of very supportive to me in
that world and that kind of helped me
create my my era of like the poetry jam
when
the poetry lounge became different dude
robin williams co-signed your poetry
[ __ ] career yeah yeah
yeah my rap my rap present with this big
book uh leaves of grass
grasped by walt whitman by stein by ron
williams what do you like about poetry
[Laughter]
i try to get into poetry too but besides
rhyming words and [ __ ] you're too much
of a beefcake bro
come on you never understand it story
you know what i'm saying
yeah it's just like filmmaking just a
story in a small form it's a story with
words that no one understands
hopefully they understand well how about
they're like roses or red violence or
blue [ __ ]
yeah give it give give bart a poem
what's one of her favorite poems
he understands it we're just putting on
the spotlight all right come on dude
you don't have any memorize
[Laughter]
yeah yeah so where are you from see
that's a little question see i grew up
in a blue collar town simply meaning the
blacks and the browns and me being in
that category plus my pots made less
than 40.
cheese a year it's clear to see that mia
be well blue collar
better yet broke most of times even
better poor but when you're young and
you're poor you don't know that you're
poor never curse you that you don't have
a bed everyone sleeps on the floor
13 in a house one bathroom someone
always knocking on the door
at least it was fun let's get back to
where we started where are you from
see where i'm from there are cops and
there are gangsters also known as
gangbangers not unlike the cops and
robbers of the movies but unlike the
movies it's not so black and white
the areas of greatness is to say it's
hard to distinguish the difference
between
being pulled over by a cop and being hit
up by a gangster both evoke a bit of
pain in the pit of your stomach i think
it's anger masked by
shame maybe i get ahead of myself let me
explain
followed by a cop follow six blocks
pulled over by the cop he looked at you
at you as if you are mark uh where are
you from
he does not wait for you to reply
instead he accuses you as you deny
you're from the east side and know sir
about your head don't look in the eyes
it's embarrassing getting pulled out the
car to sit on the curb watch the cars
drive by
but being where i'm from that's another
part of my life now when it comes to the
gang banger all you got to be strange
when he asks you where you from you can
feel it laced with danger so watch what
you say next because you're playing with
death so don't claim the east and don't
claim the west matter of fact the same
rules apply
dye your head don't look in the eyes i
ain't from nowhere man i'm just some guy
see he too sees you as a mark but they
don't really see you your face or your
heart all they see are marks
now me being me i got a few tricks up my
sleeves [ __ ] up situations i got a few
of those by simply
picking my nose that's right picking my
nose checking when the cop pulls up i
can do the heat in his eyes or the
monte carlo filled with gangsters pulls
up next to my side i pretend i don't see
them and i carefully try to pick a
booger from my nose
and for a second just a moment i'm
exposed to be a man not a mark a human
being just like you don't lie you've got
boogers too
and the cop he just continues to roll
down the street the gangsters where they
just laugh and then they just leave
sometimes when you see a little bit of
yourself and someone else it can set you
free
and the funny thing is i'm probably from
where they're from
the other side of town and i'm just
trying to get home
that's ty yeah bart dude what are you
talking about that's way better walt
whitman
it's just a wee dummy i mean outside
yeah but when i think of poetry
i don't i think like edgar allen poe
[ __ ] yeah or like shakespeare
that's a different error i know but it
sounds so much more lame when they do i
know but
when we take what we're doing now but
when you start studying it just kind of
goes back
it's like the lineage it's like watching
think about those old poems like
watching an old black and white film i
love those
that's it it's all it is it's like it's
just it's not it's different it still
means something for this day but it's
not
always direct you know why do they do so
why do they teach it that way you know
like when in school
they start old and then you go forward
why don't you just start with okay
what's upon me like oh maybe
kendrick lamar yeah well kendrick lamar
actually took from this and then they
took from this and took from this
backwards yeah if they pop that way i
would actually like the old [ __ ] because
not everyone's that cool bro it takes a
while to get back there
yeah that was really dumb with you i
felt the same way but when i teach a
class i try to do that kind of stuff too
like
kendrick what do you like right now who
you listen to because a lot of people
teach poetry
i have done some poetry workshops and
stuff like that yeah so just rapping
without beats
that's what i do there's a lot of people
that just do
free verse and just talk it's whatever
you want now it's really just
cadence and style and story that was
really good
you need to have a rhythm to it no is
that what makes it poetry
because i could be haiku wins in the
willow
yeah you can do that i always rhyme but
that's i'm one of the last guys that not
like i'm on the few people that are
rhyming in like
modern poetry leaves fall down wind
high in the sky mountains
that's it
i like it oh yeah do you know why they
do this
uh i don't know it's just poetry thing i
think it was instead of like being loud
just like because you know what because
they're doing it not just at the end
they're doing it in the middle if
someone says something that you kind of
vibe with you don't want to start
like i almost clapped a bunch of times
yeah like because the whole time i
wanted to interrupt like that's my
childhood you're talking about
i was like i picked my nose too i do it
all the time and i've been asked were
you from by a cop and a gangster on the
same day oh my god there you go
wow they asked me to be like yeah
that was great that was really cool so
cool i don't even care about the other
stuff i know well
we got a free performance i didn't know
you were into poetry wait i think i saw
your deaf comedy jam
performance though cause i went down the
rabbit hole of that one time
oh cool like i just watched all of them
back to back and i was like damn that's
cool
so i started poetry then you kind of out
of my living room like over 20 years ago
originally called dante's poetry lunch
dpo dante's poetry lounge and then that
was like
it became this you know everywhere we
went got bigger and bigger and bigger
and then i brought him other friends
the other post to help run it because i
couldn't do it every week because i was
working and then
when i dropped that off i dropped d.a
poetry lounge as a whole crew so dpl the
poetry lounge
is what became deaf poetry jam on hbo
and went to broadway and won a tony
and now before cove and even now but
it's the largest
uh weekly open mic uh in the world
is your style spoken word because i
remember that used to go down all the
time
yeah spoken word poetry whatever i think
they just read in the 90s we got written
up
our crew me shihan jamel uh poetry
dpl they're like these these the guys
that brought poetry back to la
which is not necessarily true there's a
whole lot of things going on just
brought more eyes
but they were just like i think it was
just us at our age who we were and
how popular we got and then plus i had a
whole hollywood part of what was going
on like a lot of hollywood cats would be
coming through
so many people come to the poetry lounge
you know
yeah get your get ready get your debut
ready speechless
i'm ready to get out of here but
i think a part of my comedy self or like
the immature self
spoken word used to be so funny to me no
because it can get pretty intense and
then just i don't know
i like when their voices get like really
intense well it's a cadence everything
it's just the whole culture but it's
always about like the the person that
does it right because you can say that
about anything yeah that's true
you could do it cool but there's a lot
of people that don't know because
comedians poets
are the flip side of the scene they're
the same coins that's why they're modern
day philosophers and there's good poets
and bad posters good comedians and bad
comedians
yeah but at their best you know they're
supposed to both make you think
yeah and laugh and maybe have some
emotional we're
supposed to we have the same job we're
just doing it in a different different
way but we're actually the same exact
job
yeah that's why like george carlin he
started doing a bunch of poetry like
later and no i would do a lot of shows
throughout the years at comedy store
improv like we'll go back and forth
comic poet comic poet comic poet and
just like
and we'd be talking about the same [ __ ]
that's pretty cool i know you did comedy
too
i didn't do the comedy i did i would do
a poetry set like an open mic
yeah it knows be like we just set it up
like the po the comic gets like seven
minutes and the poet gets seven minutes
and you just go back and forth sometimes
i forget that these art forms exist
because there's new ones coming out
and then like new styles of like using
technology with storytelling and stuff
or like back then you had to be able to
have first and foremost the ability to
speak in front of an audience
and not be afraid to talk in front of
people but now like
like vloggers or whatever you can be
this introvert who's scared to talk
in front of an audience but you can
record your message
on your webcam and then just you know
i think that's like modern day like
doing speeches or whatever
too performances performance yeah yeah
like like what
a lot of the uh like ryan and um
kev jumba and those guys kind of
invented like
the just the first person like
like speaking into a webcam right and
then they would edit it
and then they would construct an idea
like
yeah like they would pursue a thought or
question or whatever and i was like yeah
this is pretty dope
yeah i'm pretty sure cam girls invented
that but they were showing them
out later i know you're so big daddy i
know you're a big
daddy touch me over here the original
vlogger guys
yeah they've impact i remember when it
was happening they impacted hollywood
because
that jump cut yeah in between things
were just
was not a good cut yeah it was happening
so much that now people in hollywood you
are using it
yeah that's right it's like what the
[ __ ] you just that shot just went from
there to there
like yeah cause we're so used to
watching it through vlogs
you you see how we all influence each
other it's
crazy if you're doing a young show you
can do that yeah
and it's normal like it's not weird no
kids are gonna say that's bad filmmaking
yeah that's true sure when i went to
film school back in 2007. i couldn't do
that [ __ ] yeah like they they would
teach you it's like hey hide your cuts
right cut away to another angle so yeah
it feels seamless and all that but now
like getting right out of i ran out of
film school in like 2009
and like entering youtube it was like
everything you just learned casey
toss out the [ __ ] window yeah a whole
new world now it's crazy
today's video is brought to you by
upstart
upstart is a pretty amazing site where
you can go ahead and grab some loans up
and now what separates upstart from a
lot of these other companies that's
lending you money
well i think it's pretty awesome that it
goes based off of your education history
and so many other factors
because the number one thing that i
think is hurting a lot of my friends and
people i know
is credit card debt like credit card
debt is crazy
and if you guys don't know why it's so
bad and damaging
well there's something called apr and
this is
the same thing as interest right and
it's very high on credit cards they
could run up to like 16 to 24
so real quick if you owe like a thousand
bucks right
they're putting 24 on that annually
imagine if you can owe the same money
but now for a way
smaller percentage upstart can help you
do that and i think it's pretty amazing
because you can just sign in
you know put in your information and
within like
five minutes you'll already get the
answer if you got it or not
yeah now a lot of people they actually
have not just one credit card there'll
be multiple
and then the problem is you're trying to
manage all four credit cards you want to
pay it all
all on time they all have higher
interest rates and then it can feel like
you're
constantly losing control of your
financial situation
what's cool about upstart you can get
one loan pay all of them off now you
only have to pay
this one loan and like joe was saying
they assess more than just your credit
score your education you can get a much
better rate that way
and many times they can approve you in
five minutes and you can even get
your money the next business day which
is awesome
so don't delay go ahead and fix your
financial life and
credit score and debt problem all that
stuff go to upstart.com
off the record or go ahead and check the
link in the description box below and
you can see our promo code there
and get started with upstart that's
upstart.com
off the record my videos have awful jump
cuts
well they're just awful
yeah they're still really bad but still
you know it's just like
no but then people i don't know it's
weird because then they like the jump
cuts
you're right then it moved on to going
backwards again where
people don't want actually not even
backwards but like zero cuts
live stream now back to live streaming
yeah
which is actually better with editing
because i i do like editing but then i
hate
i hate sitting down to edit but once
you're there it's like kind of fun
because that's
actually where the story gets told yeah
your whole humor all your jokes however
you want to do it who are going to play
with that's when it gets made
yep but to sit down and do it i [ __ ]
can do
fifty thousand other things sit down and
do this [ __ ]
i wonder where poetry and like these
more campfire
style like art you know like
like poetry comedy storytelling like
just
standing in a circle and like talking
like i feel like
i mean you can do that on streaming or
whatever right but that in person
vibe in the feel it's much different in
my opinion than like doing it
online like you could still feel it
online but then that energy in an
audience
like when you perform it's just a couple
of us but we all felt it in the room
or like if you're doing a stand-up you
know open mic night you hear the
roar of the laughter and the back and
forth that energy is much more amplified
than like in the bedroom that's the
problem
even with like stand-up specials or even
like that poetry
it's a theatrical experience like you
can't watch it it's like watching those
peter pan things those theater things on
tv it just don't work
like it never feels the same even seeing
a great concert
shot it's never gonna feel as good as if
you were in that auditorium
that's true and so there's there's that
yeah i mean the problem is everyone's
trying to shoot it
yeah so that's the annoying part and
there's all that cancel culture with
that maybe when [ __ ] comes back
it'd be crazy to a poetry theater show
uh
especially comedy show where like you
gotta turn your phones in yeah
and let the comment go off i wanna hear
uncomfortable thoughts because now
everyone's scared yeah to say some [ __ ]
cause someone's gonna pull some [ __ ] out
but if everyone checks their phones in
and then they still do that and then
have a second phone
and then there was a chappelle that did
that like he took phones away but then
in the middle of the set someone still
had a phone going off yeah
[ __ ] dude yeah i wanna i wanna go back
i guess to a time where put the phone
door off
no where people were allowed to explore
thoughts
on stage or workshop ideas together
you didn't have to come with a perfect
thought yeah like that's
difficult to do and then i see so many
performers now self
editing while they're performing it is
so cringe to me
because it's like i hate when you have
to explain the joke
or preface it with like i don't mean
this about everybody's
joke we're all yeah
it's just dude a [ __ ] joke i think
you need to do a show take the phones
away have a little scrambler that
scrambles the signal so you can't
hear anything you can't you can't do
[ __ ] just cancel [ __ ] out
that might be the next move right and
then you just get to be
free like for like a small amount of
time because it's got to be a show where
all the audience have to take the
clothes off
yeah before you enter the room you have
the room a little bit warmer of course
because if you don't have it
it's like a reverse cam girl situation
whatever that's what we've been trying
to do too like with patreon and stuff
you know was trying to have like a small
little bubble right of security like
with at least your own fans that you
know it's like okay you guys understand
we grew up coming from we cool yeah you
know you're not going to take my [ __ ]
out of context because no but
it goes back to like even when we're
talking beginning conversation my
generation
even when we're going out like
celebrities only go out anymore even
before covet
because there's too much cameras there's
too many things not just a paparazzi
when we were going out and i said i see
justin battling
usher at the club on a monday night
or you know what i'm saying like imagine
if a video like that went out
they don't do that anymore so they used
to do that a lot in the
2000s yeah because i mean there was a
[ __ ] up thing you couldn't get a
certain club because it was just like
you know it's that exclusive exclusive
like people be waiting out there all
night you feel shitty because you're
like uh
you're never getting this and then
you're here because he's in there once
you get in that club you know
you'd be crazy stuff listen to milano's
birthday party at highlands you're like
oh [ __ ]
and uh but then that doesn't exist
anymore i don't know if that's ever
going to exist
yeah you know because everyone's too
scared to do something wrong so people
were just doing
house parties house parties like dan
bilzerian house parties
but everyone's recording it and mastered
everyone
recording i know you guys are part of
the people that created this whole i
know
all my stuff i record on the camera not
on the phone but i'm also
you know when i was single dating girl
you're dating the young
you know girls that are into instagram
and they they're vlogging their night
yeah and you're like are you [ __ ]
serious do you have to do this right now
what do you do what do you say to that
uh i was just like let him do it because
i'm around i mean i do it sometimes too
yeah
when we were maker we do the maker you
know disneyland thing all the time you
would all the vloggers every and
everyone
got a separate camera this is what we're
doing like
this is what i mean that's all we're
doing we're all doing it this is my
drink people just want to be along for
the ride though
i know i know but there's gotta be more
i don't know it's all good i think
there's moments people are going to get
tired like let's do it for an hour
let's do it for an hour and that's it
yeah and then and then it's a wrap
yeah p.m i think it's just a phase right
like
people are gonna watch it and the people
that are watching it will get tired of
it people that are doing it will get
tired of it and it'll evolve into
something else
but the way i see it is like humans
always want to share
we just never had the tools to people
always want to document
like every time we go back in the day
family trips parents are taking
thousands of [ __ ] pictures or
something
and then they'll they'll make albums out
of it and when people come over they'll
be like look at what i did
look at this [ __ ] that's just the same
[ __ ] you're like cool yeah
yosemite awesome but the thing is
i'm gonna flag all those photos
[Laughter]
these ones suck suck you'll get tired
they'll get tired we'll get tired but
then the next person won't
is not tired is there someone new
there's another new
cute kid that thinks interesting and
then they want to check it out
it'll turn into something else yeah but
that's just life so i don't have no
shame and i just like it is a little bit
strange really it is weird
okay yeah we're gonna vlog our whole
night yeah
this is our second date oh [ __ ] you
could expect to leave her house and
someone's recording something
it's just crazy yep which is crazy yeah
look what you guys [ __ ] did i told
you
i'll be
i feel like it brings people together
because you can humanize
the world that's a beautiful part of it
yeah dude because now technology is
getting to
countries that never had it before and
you see dudes like soy tia
going viral [ __ ] 45 43 right
he's just like he's like a cow herder in
vietnam in his little village
and it's like damn dude now back in the
day the only way you would see these
kind of kids is on
tv commercials where it's like please
feed the hungry and you're like all the
[ __ ] poor unfortunate
but you realize they're just like us and
they're just chilling and
like you know there is some i think i
can do that i had this idea like if i do
live streams like
this is the deal fans or whoever gives a
[ __ ] about thing
at three o'clock every day i'm going to
give you 10 minutes of no matter what
the [ __ ] i'm doing at 3 p.m no matter
where i'm at
or anything or meeting i'm just gonna go
live at 3 p.m so if you want to roll
with me
for 10 minutes [ __ ] at 3 p.m you're
like it's
three minutes
[Music]
you're like i got eight more minutes
left which i want to do now
but if it's a small the amount of time
that you give
it's like then that's cool i just don't
want to do it
ad nauseam forever yeah you know that
gets a little bit like whoa that's a
cool way to do it it was cool way to
compartmentalize it
because i'm sure when you're around
certain people it does get exhausting
when they're always vlogging or
something like that you're like all
right yeah you're like
no baby you are cute that's good nice
dress i got you cool
[Music]
you